- So today we're gonna talk
about building zero-CVE
container images at scale.
My name is Dale Rodriguez.
I'm a happiness engineer
and also a senior solutions
engineer at Chainguard.
So let me tell you a
little bit more about me.
I'm a certified Vuln hustler.
That means that we hustle
vulnerabilities at Chainguard.
10 years focused on product management,
security and also solutions engineering
and another seven years focusing
on cloud native security.
You can find me on LinkedIn
at the URL at the bottom
if you're feeling lucky.
And let's go to the next slide.
So what is Chainguard and why are we here?
First and foremost,
Chainguard's goal is to be
the secure source for open source.
We believe in the open source community.
We support the open source community,
but we wanted to enhance
the open source community
by securing containers, libraries
and also virtual machines
within the OSS community
so that you can run this cool stuff
in production environments
and your compliance and security people
won't bang you upside the head.
So we have over 1,818 images,
134,000 plus versions,
a whole lotta images and you
all can see the build number.
I don't even feel like saying it.
And of course no one buys the Factory.
We sell images and a
couple of other things.
These are all of the tools that we use
to build software at Chainguard.
Melange is our package manager
that helps us to build APKO packages.
Octo-STS is a GitHub security
tool for security tokens.
Sigstore is for signing.
We have a whole bunch
of Terraform providers.
And last but not least,
Malcontent will check your
container images for malware.
So there is no magic to zero CVE's.
There's a lot of automation, debugging,
a whole bunch of cloud
compute costs, testing, joy
and a lot of questioning your own sanity,
'cause this shit is very hard.
So first of all, before
we talk about the Factory,
I wanna talk a little
bit about the philosophy
of building from source.
And also, have you ever
heard of open source malware?
So when you build from source,
first of all, it allows you
to trust the source, right?
So you want to provide
depth in your defense.
And what I mean by that,
if you look at the little small diagram
over there to the right,
you'll see that if you
have a very low visibility,
limited visibility into your
awareness blinds you from risk.
What we do at Chainguard
is we want to expand
that visibility and build all the way down
to the file system itself.
So depth will mitigate uncertainty
and most importantly,
when you have this depth,
you'll be able to trust
the stuff that you build.
Also, we're building software
with more safer compiler options.
When you look at a lot
of upstream projects,
a lot of the languages aren't
compiled using safe compilers.
So we do our best to
recompile all packages
and images and I'm sorry,
binaries with safer options
so we can reduce
vulnerabilities in the stack.
So what is the Chainguard Factory?
At a high level, we're gonna
download a OSS project.
We have some cool
automation in the background
that's gonna generate a package build,
then generate another CVE
remediation if necessary.
That stuff is gonna go
into a package repository.
Those two blue boxes at the bottom
represents building that
image and testing it.
And then we're gonna push
that out to an image repo.
The top boxes that you see there,
the package and image boxes,
those are just some
examples of how we do it.
So let's dive in a little further.
The assembly line.
So essentially the Chainguard
Factory assembly line
runs right through the
middle of the Factory.
Everything touches the assembly line
and we have to keep it moving.
We're building a lot of stuff daily.
So all 1,818 of those projects
are rebuilt on a daily basis.
That's to cover for zero day CVEs
and also to maintain updates
in line with projects
from an automated fashion.
So most importantly, we
have a lot of GitHub PRs
and I'm gonna dive into those in a second.
Also, our package building
system is running on Kubernetes
and then also in that background,
we're executing our package
build tool called melange.
So as I mentioned, we really,
really have tons of PRs.
This is just a screenshot of
some version request updates.
As you can see, we have six
in this particular screenshot.
We got about 65,000k closed, 407 open.
When these are generated,
there's a new upstream release.
We have some automation that matches
the version differences.
We have GitHub commit expects.
And so essentially what we're doing
is making sure it's the right image.
Then we're gonna run build.
We're gonna do build and test
results on each of those,
and we're gonna do that twice,
because we wanna make sure that the image
is proper, functional and
most importantly, performing.
This is a sense of scale.
So in this particular slide,
we rebuild every package from source.
So in this graph, these
are the numbers of CPUs
that we spin up as we're
building these images.
So this is our all world builder.
One of the challenges about
this is when you're spinning up
this many Kubernetes nodes,
you can really have a lot of
degradation on performance
with our packaging system,
so we had to kind of bring this in-house
to make this a little bit better.
So essentially, we
spinned up about 1000 CPUs
to process this and then
we spin them back down
once the build process is completed.
So we wanna automate all the things.
We wanna monitor upstream
projects and ingest new releases.
That's why we're releasing daily.
Most importantly, we're gonna monitor
multiple version streams
of upstream projects.
So we don't just provide latest,
we provide every single tag
that's supported by the project.
And the reason why we do that
is everybody doesn't use latest.
You should not pin the latest.
God bless you if you do.
And most importantly, pinning
the multiple stream versions
allows us to maintain an EOL
upstream for up to six months.
So in the event that a
project goes into life,
we could support that project
for you after six months.
And most importantly, we're
gonna monitor the CVEs
and we're gonna scan for those CVEs
and at Chainguard, we resolve CVEs,
criticals are seven days, high, medium
and lows are resolved within 14.
And the robots do most of
the work, I don't do it.
So can't have a talk at
AWS re:Invent without AI.
So we use AI to diagnose
and fix our build errors.
It improves our tests.
It has made my life very,
very easy with submitting PRs
and it processes a lot
of good stuff for us.
But the biggest thing is that our AIs
are generating a lot of telemetry
from our build scan tests
and our test logs.
So this information allows
us to improve our Factory,
making sure that we're
making the right decisions
when we're building our software.
So this is an example of
AI kind of doing its thing.
The main thing I want to point out though
is that when this AI PR is generated,
it is also assigned to
an engineering group.
So a human does verify the
work before it's submitted.
We don't trust AI yet, we
do not wanna become Skynet.
So essentially, we're gonna make sure
that the errors and the
build logs are highlighted.
We're gonna do some
suggested fixes as well.
And then we're gonna also
triage and remediate that.
That at the moment is done by a human.
So testing, testing is also important.
Our images do not get tagged
until they pass tests.
Just because we download
and rebuild a package
and package it up into an image
doesn't mean that that's complete.
We wanna make sure that
it's fully functional
and so a lot of times what that means is,
is spinning up an actual
Kubernetes cluster,
running a real world test
of that particular project
to make sure that it's functional.
We do a little bit more
than just hello world
when we're testing these projects.
So this is kind of an example
of where when the image
comes into the PR system
or the Factory, it's gonna
spin up that test harness,
it's gonna be deployed.
Those probes will provide
the functional testing.
We'll leverage Helm, Docker
or whatever tool we use to
deploy for that particular test.
Once that runs and that's certified,
then that image is released.
So the Factory is the scale
and how we've built a
functional, scalable Factory.
So our images are always
signed with Sigstore
and pushed through our
customers' private repos.
When you become a customer of Chainguard,
you get your own pretty repository
with your domain and your images.
We release those typically within an hour.
You can clone your images
from our repository to yours.
And most importantly, we have a LDAP
and other features that allow
you to customize those images
so you can have your own
code and image program
leveraging Chainguard images.
That way we build those for you
so you don't have to manage that in-house.
And as you can see in the green,
that's essentially an
example of your name here
with a particular image type.
And then on the tag history,
you can even time travel essentially
and look up previous builds if you like.
So we also have free images.
We have about 54 of those.
Those images are latest only.
We have some base images, Python, JRE,
Ruby, Node and PHP.
And then we also have
some application images
that you can use for free,
Postgres, MariaDB,,
MongoDB, Redis and Valkey.
So we got about 54 of those and counting.
All of these free images
always have zero CVEs,
they have SBOMs.
It's essentially a free version
of our enterprise product
and you're welcome to use it.
We'd love to see what you build.
And also, enterprises,
commercials or whomever you are,
are not one size fits all.
So we build custom assembly.
Custom assembly allows you to customize
the golden images that we built
and then make them your own.
So you can add your own packages,
create your own entry points
and what this does is,
is this allows you to make our
workflows fit within yours.
The idea of building these images
is not for you to change
how you do things,
but it's more so to add a compliment
to the way that you're
currently doing business.
So you could add packages,
you can do all updates
and also they all come, they're
all signed with Sigstore,
they have SBOMs, providence and et cetera.
This last particular slide is,
we want you to Chainguard your
open source software stack.
So at the bottom, the
foundation of all of this
is all of this is the Chainguard Factory.
On top of that is the Chainguard OS.
We make and distribute
our own operating system.
This allows us to have that
seven day critical SLA,
14 day high, medium and
low for system packages,
because not at the mercy of
a third party distribution.
Most importantly, this
operating system is minimal,
has a small footprint
and believe it or not,
it was actually inspired by Alpine.
We used to have mutual support
and we got tired of being confused,
so we dropped it a few years ago.
After the Chainguard OS,
the next product is
Chainguard Virtual Machines.
Chainguard Virtual Machines are the same
as the hardened container images,
except it's a VM effort for it.
So instead of having an Nginx container,
you could have an Nginx VM with zero CVEs.
All of our images and VMs also come
in compliance flavors as well.
We have FIPS versions
of a lot of our images.
Over 700 FIPs images and those FIPS images
can also be made into Chainguard VMs.
We talked about Chainguard containers.
You see Toolchain, we
protect the Toolchain,
runtime and most importantly,
we also have Helm charts.
They are called Chainguard
IAMGuarded charts.
When Bitnami put their
stuff behind a paywall,
we decided to step up and make charts
to serve the community.
So we have about roughly
about 40 to 50 charts
that you can use with
Chainguard Helm charts.
And then last but not
least, Chainguard Libraries.
So Chainguard Libraries
is one of our newer,
more exciting features of where instead
of using PyPI for example,
for your Python packages,
you would use Chainguard.
Those packages will come
with malware protection,
provenance and also CVE remediation.
Currently we have Python
and Java available.
JavaScript is in early access
and the goal of Libraries
is to try to secure every open
source library that we can.
Up on the roadmap, we'll more
than likely be going RUST
followed by a few others over
the next couple of quarters.
And again, the idea is to
secure the entire stack.
So one main thing I want to
note on Chainguard Libraries,
one of the nice things
about Chainguard Libraries
is that you still can use
third party library providers.
We don't try to lock you in
into our Libraries product,
our container product or VMs.
They're all customizable.
Another thing on Libraries,
especially with Python,
y'all know Python got about
700,000 plus packages.
We're trying to work towards some balance.
We haven't gotten that far yet,
but we got about 20 to 30,000.
We're still growing.
Java, we have over 50,000 packages.
JavaScript, I can't
tell y'all the numbers,
'cause y'all didn't sign an NDA.
So that's the Factory.
Couple of key points.
The packages are built from source.
They really, really
are hardened by default
by expert humans.
I promise, we don't use AI for everything.
They're updated and patched quickly.
That's mostly automated.
That's what helps us to build at scale.
They're minimal container
images built from packages,
they're reproducible, they're secure
and they're tested on real clusters.
They're rebuilt consistently
to pick up package updates
and most importantly, they're
delivered hot and fresh
to your door like a pizza.
The VM images are at the exact same
and then the libraries
are a bit different.
They're built from a
verified upstream source.
They're malware scan and they
also have CVE backporting.
One distinct difference with Libraries
than our images and our container product,
is that we essentially backport
about three years back.
So with images and VMs,
we're not trying to support
3-year-old versions,
but from a package's perspective,
we know that some dev houses
are still using their favorite
Java package from like 1995.
So we want to have an
ability for those customers
to be able to migrate to
a secure form of a package
and kind of not leave
them out in the dust.
Thank y'all for coming to my talk.
I appreciate y'all.
(crowd cheering)